[♫ Йде виклик на телефон ♫]
Так, їдемо.
Ой, не знаю...
Федоровичу, коли ми вертаємось?
Або в середу, або в листопаді.
Каже: «Або в середу, або в листопаді».
[сміється]
Ще поїхати не встиг,
а вже дзвонить: «Коли ти приїдеш?».
— Восьмий рік війни в нас іде.
— Так.
Все по колу, все по колу.
«Повернись живим» — це фонд
компетентної допомоги армії,
який рятує життя.
І щодня займається тим,
щоб підвищити обороноздатність України.
З фондом я познайомився 2015 року.
Тоді я був військовослужбовцем,
фонд допомагав нашій військовій частині.
Так у нас склалися дружні контакти
з частиною військового відділу,
з тими хлопцями,
які безпосередньо нас же і вчили,
нам допомагали й іншим,
з ким ми служили.
Як і більшість волонтерських середовищ,
фонд з'явився навесні 2014 року,
коли розпочалось активне
протистояння на сході України.
Як і багато інших людей,
співзасновники фонду просто
почали допомагати військовим.
Спочатку це були бронежилети,
потім це були перші тепловізори,
потім це були перші коптери, машини.
Я коли вийшов з госпіталю,
це друга половина 2015 року.
Спочатку там самі купляли
ці планшети, ну, збирали гроші,
просто розвозили військовим.
Ну, а потім почалася вже робота...
В принципі...
[По] навчанню, поясненню.
Як і будь-яка нормальна організація,
ми існуємо в такому режимі
постійного хаосу,
тому у нас постійно щось
кудись приїжджає,
виїжджає, привозиться,
завозиться тощо.
І час від часу хлопці, повертаючись
з війни, привозять якісь трофеї,
інколи це наша техніка знищена.
Фактично, нашою спеціалізацією завжди була тепловізійна техніка.
Ще з 2014 року ми зрозуміли,
що безглуздо возити все підряд.
І треба робити якісь акценти
з точки зору «ціна-результат».
І нічна оптика — це якраз
та точка прикладання зусиль,
де, вкладаючи умовну гривню,
ви отримуєте максимальний результат.
Це те, що рятує наші життя.
На сьогодні, 2021 року,
кожна бригада збройних сил,
яка перебуває на лінії зіткнення,
десь на 50% укомплектована тепловізійною
технікою від «Повернись живим».
Як і будь-яка організація,
яка народжується,
вона проходить якісь етапи розвитку.
Ми їх так само проходимо.
З часом фонд змінює
свій напрямок роботи,
тому що змінюється війна,
змінюються потреби,
і переходить від просто допомоги армії
на якусь системну реформу збройних сил,
сектору безпеки і оборони,
на аналітику, на роботу з ветеранами.
І в нас є медійна складова.
У нас найбільша в Україні
Facebook-сторінка.
Тобто ми є таким потужним
інформаційним гравцем в інфополі країни.
Ми зараз більш плідно працюємо
з міжнародними організаціями,
з урядами країн-партнерів,
які нам допомагають.
Ми реалізовуємо декілька
міжнародних проєктів.
Намагаємося їм доносити
про стан справ і про те,
щоб їхня допомога спрямовувалася
ефективно і в тих напрямках,
де вона дійсно треба.
— Зараз війна технологій.
— Так.
Війна майбутнього.
Ми навчаємо, як з різних типів зброї
стріляти з закритих позицій.
Ліпимо з того,
що можна.
Ліпимо на результат,
воно працює.
Це на сьогодні головний
безпілотник збройних сил.
Фактично кожен батальйон має один,
два, три таких або інших продуктів DJI,
які виконують функцію передової розвідки
в першій смузі оборони противника.
Це не військовий продукт,
тому час від часу вони,
як і будь-що на війні, знищуються,
час від часу вони ламаються.
Як це?..
Втрата техніка — це чиєсь
врятоване життя або здоров'я.
І ми займаємося їхнім ремонтом.
І з цього року ми запустили
інструкторський відділ,
який займається навчанням військових,
як їх правильно експлуатувати.
Тому ми вважаємо себе фондом
компетентної допомоги армії,
тому що ми не просто віддаємо,
ми це ще й контролюємо
і вчимо цим користуватися.
Війна мінялась, змінювались
запити, все це росло.
Так само виростали всі
ці програмні продукти,
вони всі мінялись.
Не змінювались тільки знання людей,
які постійно треба оновлювати.
Багато нових приходить,
їм треба все заново розказувати.
Вчити з нуля.
Є, наприклад, люди, які могли би
працювати так, як ми,
але вони служать.
Взагалі у фонді більшість людей —
це колишні військовослужбовці,
учасники цієї війни,
тому якоюсь мірою ми називаємо себе
ветерансько-волонтерським фондом.
І це круто.
Ми шукаємо людей, які наші.
Ми керуємося не тільки
фаховими компетенціями,
але й (більшою мірою) відповідністю
цієї людини цінностям організації.
Це про готовність бути з командою,
готовність постійно розвиватися,
вчитися, і тут народжується
саморозвиток.
Ми не контролюємо кожного,
у нас вільний робочий графік в офісі,
у нас кожен сам знає,
що йому робити.
Ми відповідаємо за наш результат,
ми відповідаємо за військових,
яких ми вчимо,
ми відповідаємо за допомогу,
яку ми завозимо,
ми відповідаємо за кожну гривню,
яку ми зібрали для того,
щоб вона ефективно дійшла
до кінцевого користувача,
до якогось військовослужбовця
в якомусь окопі.
Є пул людей, яких ми називаємо
волонтерами і які нам допомагають.
Це різні люди: це фотографи,
монтажери, ті, хто пише нам тексти.
Таких людей, напевно,
десь до сотні,
хтось це може тільки раз у рік,
а хтось може щотижня.
Є пул людей,
які з нами багато років,
які допомагають фінансово
як з України, так і з-за кордону.
Це теж дуже різна категорія людей.
Просто звичайні українці, до керівників
якихось великих бізнесів, компаній,
які зацікавлені в тому,
щоб Україна перемогла в цій війні,
щоб збройні сили були ефективними
й війна переросла в таку формацію,
коли Україна все ж таки повертає
своє і відновлює свої кордони,
і зникає оця загроза
повномасштабного вторгнення,
яка є постійно.
Це ось планшет 317-й.
Він отримав уламок,
який не наскрізний,
тобто, можливо, він комусь
врятував життя,
якщо він висів у такому
підсу́мку на грудях.
Вони дозволяють працювати
з закритих вогневих позицій.
Суть в чому: тут софт [програмне
забезпечення], тут мапа.
Ви прив'язуєтесь до точки XY («стояння»),
вибираєте тип техніки, боєприпас,
позначаєте ціль,
куди ви хочете влучити,
і планшет вам обраховує,
що вам треба зробити.
Скорочує час від команди «вогонь» до безпосереднього
відкривання вогню, з одного боку,
а з іншого — це зменшує кількість
математичних обрахунків,
які військовому десь треба
робити в голові або в записнику.
Ти стоїш десь далеко,
тебе не видно, десь знизу,
захований рельєфом
місцевості або в укритті.
І по вибраних координатах
ведеш вогонь, не бачачи цілі.
На ціль дивиться
або камера, або безпілотник.
Калькулятор тобі каже, на скільки
умовно повернути ствол чи башту
і підняти на який кут,
щоб прилетіло туди, куди треба.
З урахуванням усіх складових:
метео, балістики, висоти тощо.
Зрозуміли?
У військового відділу є такі
два основні напрямки:
інструкторський і, відповідно, хлопці,
які займаються безпосередньо
роботою з військовими.
Що вони роблять?
Вони їздять по підрозділах,
по частинах,
вони дізнаються потреби.
Вони там формують
список, що потрібно.
[Він] подається на бухгалтерію,
бухгалтерія це закуповує,
воно приходить на склад,
тут воно все обліковується.
Потім хлопці це забирають.
Ну, якщо є можливість,
то передається Новою Поштою
або військовими проїздом в Києві,
якщо ні, то ми завозимо,
і цей процес 24/7.
Фактично, за рік команда фонду виїжджає
сотні тисяч кілометрів буквально.
Рано чи пізно війна закінчиться.
Очевидно, закінчиться перемогою України,
але в країні лишиться величезна
кількість ветеранів, учасників війни,
в Україні лишиться величезна
кількість родин, які когось втратили,
дітей-сиріт або напівсиріт.
Це величезна соціальна проблема,
яка є у всіх країнах,
які воювали,
і з цим потрібно щось робити.
І ми як ГО хочемо сприяти
вирішенню цієї проблеми.
Ми створили ветеранський відділ,
ми намагаємося через спорт,
затягнувши учасників війни,
захисників у спорт,
допомогти їм повернутися
в нормальне життя.
І у нас є приклади людей,
які були фізично сильно травмовані,
і через участь у наших заходах,
змаганнях, у самостійній роботі
вони поверталися
до нормального життя.
Є люди, які були на межі самогубства,
а зараз вони вчать інших,
як долати ці всі проблеми.
Таких історій багато.
Інший напрямок —
це розвиток ветеранського бізнесу.
Є багато різного ветеранського
бізнесу в Україні,
який розвивається,
який хоче рости, зрозуміло,
і ми намагаємося цьому сприяти.
Десь це треба просто навчання,
якісь юридичні консультації,
десь — це просування
в соціалках [соцмережах].
Це те, на що є запит і те,
чим ми намагаємося допомогти.
Волонтерський рух 2014 року
з'явився не через те,
що нам всім не було
чим зайнятися.
Це якоюсь мірою наслідок  бездіяльності
або неефективності держави.
Люди не придумали нічого кращого,
як почати виконувати функцію держави.
Замість громадсько-демократичного
контролю, як це є в Європі, у Штатах,
замість аналітики,
якихось соціальних проєктів,
ми продовжуємо вчити снайперів,
продовжуємо вчити саперів,
возити їм якусь допомогу,
яку б мала вирішувати держава
за бюджетні кошти.
Я просто наводжу курсор на цей
орієнтир і натискаю другий глобус.
Перша дія, друга дія.
У вас три дії, три кнопки.
Дві з них — зелена і, та що зліва.
Навідник, хто навідник?
Я.
Як тебе звати?
Влад.
Коротше, дивись:
гострячком попади в неї.
От сам гострячок, щоб
десь вище-нижче — пофіг, де.
По центру, по центру
бери її, по центру.
У цьому ми досить плідно
працюємо зі збройними силами
на рівні головнокомандувача,
на рівні родів, видів таким чином,
щоб наша допомога
не конкурувала з тим,
що робить держава,
а доповнювала її.
Частина наших програм впроваджена
у збройних силах — як навчальні [програми].
Коли на фронті з'являється щось нове,
ми одразу ж це впроваджуємо
у свої навчальні програми,
таким чином, ми гнучкі
у своїй роботі.
Поки держава щось змінить
у навчальній програмі,
на війні вже п'ять разів
усе зміниться.
Наша перевага перед усіма іншими
схожими організаціями в тому,
що ми, напевно,
єдині в Україні,
хто має доступ до всіх військ на всіх
рівнях і може подавати об'єктивну,
достовірну інформацію
на запит про щось.
Ми незалежні від будь-кого,
у нас повністю диверсифіковане
фінансування.
І це дозволяє нам робити те,
що ми хочемо,
те, що ми вважаємо за правильне,
і з тим результатом,
який би ми хотіли.
Заплутано пояснив, ще раз.
Так?
На вісім, на свисток — 30.
Отам правіше у нас ціль.
Я рахую азимут на ціль.
Він умовно 185°.
Калькулятор тобі ці всі речі одразу
враховує і дає тобі чіткий кут
з урахуванням і різниці висот, і вітру,
і його напряму, і його швидкості.
Тобі головне — туди
підтягнути метеодані.
І «вогонь».
Донбас хаотично замінований сильно,
і ще не одне десятиліття
ми будемо його розміновувати.
Кількість втрат від мін — десь 20-30%.
У нас є два інструктори
з мінної безпеки,
це два старших офіцери,
колишні військовослужбовці,
учасники війни
з величезним досвідом.
Є програма підготовки,
вона розписана у нас по днях,
по навчальних модулях, з імітацією,
з практичними компонентами.
Це все багаторічна
відпрацьована історія,
яка й адаптується постійно
під реалії війни,
з якою ми взаємодіємо щодня.
Це робота, яка подекуди
забирає увесь вільний час,
це робота подекуди
з якоюсь небезпекою для життя.
Вона не регулюється
якимось робочим графіком.
Специфіка роботи така,
що якщо на фронті
загострення десь,
отже, ми всі мобілізуємося.
Мене особисто якоюсь мірою мотивує
ця регулярна дотичність до військ.
Я намагаюсь раз на місяць хоча б
їздити у війська і щоб просто бачити,
що на це є запит,
це потрібно, це працює,
це дає результат —
отже, треба працювати далі.
Це не просто про роботу,
а це про те,
що з нами можна допомогти
глобально України у війні з Росією.
Дехто дізнається,
що ми на Сході,
то [кажуть]: «Заїдьте до нас,
ще раз до нас.
Бо тут пам'ятаю,
а тут не пам'ятаю.
Так, там треба щось...
Ось тут зелена кнопка,
а там та, що зліва, десь поділась».
Технічні моменти, деталі,
щось підказати, щось виправити.
Фонд — це одна з небагатьох
інституцій в Україні,
які можуть системно
впливати на державу
і змушувати її робити щось
правильне через медіавплив,
через міжнародні інституції,
через пряму роботу з владою.
Ми є позитивним подразником
для держави.
Це не тільки про волонтерів,
це загалом про якесь
громадське середовище,
яке здатне проактивно
маленькими силами
змушувати державу рухатися
в правильному векторі.
І це не стосується тільки війни.
Люди, які займаються
тваринами, безпритульними,
екологією і деревами тощо — це все
важливі складові цього всього руху.
Ми є хорошим прикладом для інших,
для інших середовищ, що це можливо,
не треба думати,
що нічого не можна змінити.
В Україні можна зробити,
змінити будь-що.
Треба мати велике бажання
і готовність трохи виділити часу.
І трошки почекати.
Те, що ми зробили 2013 року, 2014 року,
ми — суспільство, українці, народ,
це є те, що Росія точно не враховувала
у своїх будь-яких стратегіях, планах.
І, на мою думку,
це якраз те,
що дозволило нам
не втратити державність.
Коли треба буде — величезна кількість
людей знову мобілізується,
включиться і буде
ремонтувати техніку,
варити борщі,
возити бронежилети,
стояти в чергах у військкомати тощо.
І це той фактор, який робить
українське суспільство,
напевно, унікальним
на тлі інших суспільств.
І якоюсь мірою це компенсує
недоліки нашого суспільства.